so back in 1995 javascript was created
by Brendan Eich right and he did it in
10 days which is pretty crazy the other
is what most the web is built of now so
javascript is 18 years old now so it's
like legal to drink in some countries I
saw someone on Twitter saying that they
think they've seen JavaScript drunk many
years ago a lot of the time quite like
that but in 2010 another team set about
like you know making a new language and
you know from what we know now of the
web we know how they the whole web spot
together and the kind of tools we need
and that team is the dart team and his
talk about it big warm welcome to
cephalad and Kasper lund ok thanks Jake
so we won't be playing the Kenny G we
don't want you guys to fall asleep this
is start for the modern web developer my
name is Seth Ladd I'm a developer
advocate with the chrome and dart team
and I'm cast Bolin diamond engineer here
at Google I work as a tech lead on the
dark platform and before I ventured into
doctorate or I spend a lot years on
optimizing v8 and the optimizing
compiler in there ok so many of you know
dart as a language and sure it's a
structured scalable familiar language
but it's also I like to think of it as a
batteries included platform there's a
great core set of libraries things like
collections things like a stinkers
programming futures streams things like
numbers bullion's dates times we also
ship a collection of productive tools a
dart editor and analyzer to give you
warnings and errors a package manager
we've actually called pub because you
played darts in a pub we also ship a
virtual machine which runs dart code
natively you can run that vm on the
command line or on the server and you
can also embed it in client browsers but
probably most importantly we ship a
compiler to javascript so the dart code
you see here today and the dart the dart
apps that you'll be writing you can
compiled it down to essentially equi
script 5 and run it across modern
browsers desktop and laptop you might
have heard recently we launched dart one
point oh so a big milestone for us
hopefully exciting for you guys the big
point of this really yeah thank you
okay the journey starts here really
frozen for you the big point here they
take aways it's now stability you can
count on we've been open source since
about october two thousand eleven and
gotten tons of feedback from internal
developers external developers
hackathons code labs and we've collected
at all and launched what is now a stable
language stable core libraries for you
to build Production apps on so now is
the right time to try it okay so when I
said you can use dart today I I think
actually mean you can use dart like in
the next hour so we're going to do a
lightning tour the syntax structure and
semantics to show you how familien easy
it is to get started so dart a by design
is very easy to learn we have semicolons
we have curly braces in fact we got a
little flak when we first launched dark
people like why do you make the next big
Haskell and we're like we want more than
five users and so we wanted to make sure
that you guys can totally understand
this code we've run hackathons and code
labs people get it so familiar classes
but just because it's a familiar
language you can dive into in about an
hour doesn't mean we can't take this
opportunity to introduce new features
for instance with constructors what are
we always doing constructors this that x
equals x this type y equals y this is
getting boring so dart says hey if the
name of the field is the same as the
constructor parameter just say this dot
strength in this case and that would be
sugar to a disk strength equal strength
just those nice addition to make this
feel more terse more scripty speaking of
scripty a dart has operator overriding
to plus minus etc that's in this
language we also named optional
parameters again it's a structured
language may look like the structured
language you've been using but it has
those features that allow you to write
have a tourist programming experience
that you might be more familiar with in
scripting languages in fact this case
here hands is an optional parameter but
also as a default value of one so say
more without typing more we also support
one line functions this is critical a
lot of callbacks going on in web
programming a lot of times you want to
do really small inline function literals
we support that with the fat arrow
syntax and we also have string
interpolation making a very easy and
quick to create strings just dollar sign
variable or expression and it's right
there's a lot easier than doing string
builders or string concatenation
okay so dart is its own language it's
not just the syntax that masks and other
syntax we we have our own clean
semantics so we want to turn more of
these wat moments which I'm not even
sure what's going on here into the
totally awesome atomic dinosaur nucular
rocks we want you to have more on the
right less on the left okay so some
examples of the cleaned-up Samantha's
give you a more logical programming
experience and dart only true is truth
II there you go now you know the truth
you rules good job okay there is no
undefined only null yes totally cleaned
up okay no type coercion with like
things like double equals and plus so
when you try to do something funky we're
gonna tell you okay pop quiz time here's
a string hello we call dot missing which
obviously does not exist on string what
would you want to happen at this point
undefined you I don't want them to find
I want to be told that there's no
missing method on string and sure enough
at run time when you hit code like this
the program tells you with a very clean
error so much more logical programming
experience okay if you were to compare
at hello which is a string is a greater
than one I think this returns false but
actually I'm not really sure why so what
would you want this to happen right you
want you want an heir you want to be hey
man string does not have an instance
method greater than you get told at
runtime exactly where the problem
happened much more logical programming
experience okay variable scope this
one's a little bit longer so take a look
at this we have a main function if true
there's foo and then print foo but
there's also a top-level foo so the
question I have for you is when i run
this what will it print and you say yes
it's 50-50 chance top top level right
this prints top level and dart no
variable hoisting it's a totally logical
lexical scope lexical analysis of what's
going on you hand most developers is
code they will be able to understand
what's going on here speaking of lexical
scope even this is lexically scoped in
dar this is the one of the things that
totally tripped me up earlier here's a
class awesome button and in its
constructor you set up a click handler
and when the button is clicked called
this line atomic dinosaur rock well what
is this at this point the
I secretly scope this that is an
instance of Awesome button you give most
people this code and they will tell you
what method this is calling on which is
I think a pretty big improvement okay so
that's a little bit on the semantics and
and a little bit on the syntax but dart
is also designed to scale from just a
couple lines of code you can certainly
write a 10 line dart script and have a
look very scripty but you can scale all
the way up to millions of lines of code
now we saw functions we saw classes we
have mix-ins we have interfaces I want
to talk about libraries which is a nice
piece that help you modularize your code
dart libraries are very flexible you
simply define a file as a library you
can import libraries from the core SDK
you can import libraries you know from
other people or other files and then you
can define any number of top-level
constructs in the library so no more
like one public class profile thing if
you come from Java so in this case two
classes and even a top-level function
and dart you don't have to wrap
everything in a class if you don't want
to so nice scalable structure fee to
grow so hopefully you guys saw that this
is a language you can start using right
away but of course we use dart to get
onto the web and to get on the web you
have to compile dart to JavaScript and
to do yet and just show you how it works
I'll turn over to Casper to tell you all
about dart to J's oh thank you seth so
finally now i can say something that's
wonderful so i'm going to say a little
bit about how we compile to efficient
javascript and it's very very important
to us to make sure the dark runs really
well on all modern browsers so we put a
lot of effort into that that area so our
goals are fairly simple we want to
generate small code we want generate
fast code and we want to make sure that
we retain the nice clean proper dot
semantics by a while doing so so simple
goals is a good starting point but to do
this and do it efficiently we need a
real optimizing compiler something that
doesn't just do like a one-to-one
translation in a simple way we actually
need a lot of the meet modern kampala
techniques we've learned to love from
other see more involved projects like v8
so we need function inlining we need
loop invariant code motion we need
global layer number and we need a lot of
these things ty propagation we unload
elimination dead code elimination and
much much more so we need a lot of
things in this compiler we want to do a
good job and optimizing your code so you
don't have to worry
so let's take a look at a very simple
dark message just to give you an
impression of what we actually translate
the code to here's a main method that
allocates a few points and then we
compute the distance between these
points very simple code luckily a simple
dark method actually compiled a
relatively simple JavaScript too so you
will allocate points to simply the same
way as you would expect it to the only
real difference here is that when you
call the distance to method we actually
encode the D arity the number of
parameters passed in the method name now
why don't we do that the reason why we
do that is because in JavaScript were
allowed to pass any number of arguments
too few or too many it doesn't really
matter but usually it leads to weird and
surprising behavior at runtime if you do
that so we want to be little bit
stricter there so to live by darts
proper semantics rules there we actually
have to check that you're calling with
the right number of parameters and the
fastest way of doing that is just
encoding in the method name if you call
with too many parameters you'll get an
error that that method does not exist so
when you have large applications and you
need some sort of tool to make sure that
you're not actually shipping too much
code to your clients in particular in a
setup where you have a nice rich set of
core libraries and a nice set of third
pile average you can include you want to
make sure that whatever you ship to your
clients is only the needed bits not all
the other stuff to do that we have an
implementation of an algorithm called
tree shaking in the compiler it works a
little something like this if you have a
application that has a main method and
perhaps a few other methods close by foo
and bass but it's only calling the foo
method and and maybe the foo method in
returns calls code pulled in from
another library the bar method on the on
the right the library might actually
have unused parts to like the boo
function here we want the dark J's
compiler and to actually take this set
of methods like the transitive closure
of everything that you you have
available to you and shake it real good
and get all the stuff that you actually
not using out of the system it's a
process called tree shaking we do that
and the result is a lot smaller it only
contains main foo and bar the needed
parts so to implement this in the
compiler we actually go through a few
steps first we read all your dark
sources we don't actually parse them a
fully we don't look into all the message
which
look at the structure of your code find
all the imports look at the libraries
that you you pen down and read those
into when we have everything read in
that way and we know the structure of
your code we can actually start in doing
this first level of tree shaking we have
two levels this is the first one and
this actually is what we call the
resolution tree shaking and resolution
is the process of not really compiling
code but just trying to figure out what
we're referring to at certain points in
the code so it actually starts by
looking at the main function and look at
what kind of flashy or instances of
which classes you allocate in there and
which other message you're calling all
those methods needs going to accuse that
we can process them parse them get them
resolved and you just keep doing that
until nothing new is added to the queue
and then you're done it's relatively
simple to do this and it gives us a good
approximation of like cutting down
everything but only based on method
names we can do a little bit better so
once you're done with that we actually
stop the process all over again in the
compilation queue and this is where we
actually will start looking at what you
really put inside your inside your
methods and do data flow analysis and we
will track how types flows through that
code and that gives us more information
about what you're actually needing it so
it submit and we do the last level of
the treating at that point the result is
that we do a really good job in making
sure that the things that you really
don't need are not pulled into your
application finally we actually emit the
code to a single jas file so you can run
it in your browser fairly simple stuff I
love this because this is the tools
helping me I mean I don't need to be
crafting my application I just let the
tool analyze my program take care of it
that's the way it should be so let's
take a look at how this actually works
in practice just to give you a feel for
how dark jas does it's magic I'm going
to dive into a well-known and algorithm
it's a constraint solving algorithm the
right the reason why I'm choosing this
one is that it's a well-understood and
piece of code it's been used to
benchmark lots of different language
limitations over the years it's actually
part of the the octane benchmark Linus
mentioned this morning so it's a
well-known piece of code it is
structured it has inheritance and
classes and and everything we need to do
I should do a good job and making your
code run fast so let's take a look at it
Delta blues a constraint solver what
does that mean well basically it's a
fairly abstract thing
works on and constraints on variables
constraints can be like one or a one-way
or two-way their binary or unary
constraints of different kinds and they
can be used to post for instance model
the constraints involved in laying out
something on your screen I'm pretty sure
that some of the things you just heard
about from Eric actually uses constraint
and think that that internally one when
building layout so Delta blues an
implementation of such a beast it uses
constraints and there's a nice hierarchy
of them with unary and binary
constraints and and variables let me
show you a piece of code from this thing
to make a little bit more concrete this
is a function from the from the Delta
blue algorithm it's fairly simple you
don't have to understand all the details
here but just note that the way work
series that you take a variable V and
you try to figure out all the
constraints that actually consume that
variable and put them in a list that
it's also passed in as a parameter
hopefully this code is reasonably
readable to you and it's dart code and
to me this looks like what I represented
a code a lot of us would write yeah so
am in Dart we have an optional static
type system so you do not have to write
the types if you do they don't want to
sometimes it's nicely with the document
what a pair under means which you I
didn't done it here but it's important
to us to to make it clear that the the
types that you put in are not actually
used for optimization purposes because
we don't really know if you want to type
them in so we don't want to force you
into typing them in the place where you
don't want to so I can go ahead and
remove them and they might have to be
incorrect they could be incorrect yeah
anyway I've gone ahead and removed the
types the semantics of this algorithm is
exactly the same no differences at all
it's just a little bit shorter and maybe
a little bit harder to understand but
anyway the code is there it's the same
thing and this is what we're going to
try to optimize so first attempt
actually compound this code to
javascript is somewhat large so this is
the unoptimized version of the the
method you just saw it it compiled two
out of five hundred and something
characters it's a little bit too long I
don't know I'm not even sure you can
read it in the back of the other hand of
the whole here but it works it has the
right semantics everything works as
specified and it runs reasonably well
but it
I hope you agree it's simply not good
enough like we want to do a lot better
so let's try to dive into how we
actually do better than just this blob
of code even though the semantics is
really important to us we also really
care about performance so what makes
this big well this is just one of
examples one of the examples of why this
code is a little bit bigger what we'd
like so SF mentioned we have strict
cement is about how what you can compare
two numbers for instance so we don't
want to run into issues when you end up
emitting JavaScript code that just ends
up comparing numbers and strengths for
instance because we don't really want to
rely on that behavior so in this case
we're reading see if I can get this to
progress there we go so we're reading
the length of something that that
probably isn't array we're not quite
sure so we don't know that the link is
actually a number so before we continue
to actually compare this length against
a real number we have to make sure that
it actually is a number so we enter
insert an explicit check in the code
that makes sure that we don't end up
relying on this somewhat surprising
behavior of JavaScript where you can
compare numbers against strings and get
some result out so this adds code more
checks so our challenge is fairly simple
we want to have clean semantics
unsurprising behavior but we do not
really want those extra checks when
you're compiling to JavaScript so how
can we go about doing that the trick is
right behind me global optimizations so
we really need to do better and we need
to do like more aggressive optimization
from the code to make it end up being
very fast and very good so let's look at
that first up dart is structured it has
classes it has methods it has a good
structure we can actually do whole
program analysis so when we compile the
program we can look at every single bit
in it and we can actually understand
what's going on that's a huge win for us
this allows us to actually do code
navigation and great refactoring tools
but maybe even more and more dear to my
heart is that we can also do a global
comparison optimizations so we can
actually analyze your code understand
the dependence between things may be so
certain extent better than what you
actually care to do yourself as a
developer and then we can optimize based
on that it's pretty powerful one of the
things that we do and one of things that
really were
well for something like delta blue and
for most applications in general is that
we infer types we compute what types we
actually will see at runtime at
different points in the code in the way
that works is here's a simple example of
how that works main function calls foo
that cause a bar that calls foo again
basically so a bunch of function is
calling each other so how do we infer
types for the parameters of these things
how do we get the compiler more
information well we start by looking at
main so it's very simple and by
analyzing main we can see that foo is
actually called with a ninja 2 parameter
ok so far so good so we analyze foo
under the assumption that is called with
an inch of parameter do we learn
something from that sure bar is so
apparently also called one entry
parameter so far so good we can continue
this game a little bit so we end up in
bar and we realize that if bar is called
with an initiative parameter then it
ends up calling foo with a string
interpolated version of that parameter
which is a string so foods now call with
the string too so we have to go back and
iterate so who is now apparently also
called a string that means bar is called
referring to and finally inside the bar
method we realize that that means the
print is caught with a string so far so
good all in all the compiler can
actually conclude that x and y are both
either integers or strings this is a
very very simple example but their works
really well in practice for for large
apps too so let's look at Delta blue and
see how that actually works there it's
pretty simple so there are a couple of
things do we want to infer tax for for
instance the two parameters a B and call
and the the infer actually does that by
looking at all the call sites that call
at constraints consuming too and we
actually learn that V is either null or
a variable and that call cannot be no it
always is a JavaScript array containing
only subclass the front of the class
constraint that's pretty powerful so
that's good to know for us the rest of
the method you can also be analyzed and
we can learn something about all these
concerts in there so we can actually get
a pretty full picture of what the types
in here are so I've just listed them
here you don't have to look at all the
details but this is very good
information for our compiler to have and
it does is without running a program to
statically analyze just looking at the
program this is a global analysis at
compile time so let's make this
and play to our advantage so here's the
code again without type inferencing 526
characters so first thing up like we
know B is either Nala or a variable so
we can we can do a little bit better
than just calling the scatter on it so
we can actually see that it always has a
property determined by we just fetch it
simple stuff there are the things that
we can win even more about recognising
for instance be the variable constraints
since these are variables the
constraints in there is always an array
of constraints so we don't have to go
through this I calling a lengths getter
and calling an index operator we can
just do like the the real JavaScript way
just fetch the length and just index
into the array simple stuff even better
we know that we did constraints that
length is is actually an integer so this
whole notion of checking whether or not
is a number goes away so that is a
helpful thing it's starting to improve
now the condition that we have in the
loop is turning simpler we can change
the while loop into a for loop and at
that point we're already down to thirty
three percent smaller than the original
code I showed you we have more to go but
it's pretty simple stuff call is an
array so this calling add on it and in a
weird way is not really necessary so we
can just use the JavaScript push method
do that for you looks good even further
the t1 is initialized in a simple way so
that can just move into the for loop and
we're down to 41 percent smaller than
the original JS output it's likely to
get there see is known to be a subclass
of constraint and it cannot be null
we've inferred that so this whole notion
of checking whether or not see is now
before doing a comparison this is
necessary because of knowledge undefined
in JavaScript by the way we don't have
to worry about that because at least see
canopy know so we can simplify the code
it's a good thing finally we know that
calling is satisfied on c actually
always return a boolean and into is the
only truth you value in dark so usually
we have to compare against true before
we branch on it but because a boolean is
always either true or false it's just
fine we can get rid of that last thing
and there you have it and an optimized
version of this method that runs fast
it's much smaller but it still has
exactly the same semantics it's just
we've proven that we didn't need some of
these checks so what's the do before
well here's the graph of that over time
so the top line is the native dart VM
running the Delta blue algorithm so you
see that that's the best performance we
have and it really comes from the fact
that dart is designed from the get go to
be an efficient language so we have a
very good implementation of that the
next two lines might be more interesting
in this context the yellowish line is
actually a v8 running a handwritten
version of a delta blue benchmark this
is the octane version of the delta blue
benchmark that you where you might have
seen in other places as you can see v8
improves on that over time slowly and
that's that's a very good thing for the
entire web may be more interesting to me
at least is that the dart2js generated
co has improved a lot on this benchmark
it's still the same v8 that runs it it's
just that the code we generate is
actually a little bit faster than the
handwritten version how could that be
well basically we do optimization that
you probably don't want to do by hand
because we know the entire structure of
the app we can do some inlining for you
and some sometimes in code motion things
like that for your loops that you
probably don't care to do by hand so
it's a little bit faster in general what
we see is that we're very close to
handwritten jobs with performance on and
everything so there are cases where
we're faster and of course there're case
where a little bit small bit slower so
anyway the performance looks really
promising and it's nice to be able to
write in a very clean language and get
good performance so let's let's take a
look at how you actually go about using
this dark thing in a real setting yeah
thanks Casper so that start to Jess a
little bit about the workflow how and
when do you apply that compiling
JavaScript of course is great but I
don't want to do that every time I want
this quick iterations that that the web
is known for so what does it look like
well we have a build of chromium with
the dart virtual machine embedded in it
we've actually called dartium and that's
where you spend most of your time those
your quick edit reload cycles so let's
look at what that what that feels like
here's a build of dart editor you don't
have to use dart editor but it does ship
with a project that's a stripped-down
version of eclipse in fact I like to
show this I showed this screen to
somebody and they're like oh you have a
bug you're missing like 78 more
preferences in there like no no actually
we took those out so it's optimized for
writing dart code probably the best way
to get started is let's just create a
sample app so luckily Eric showed us
polymer before
dart has been porting polymer polymer
dard so we were totally in bed with this
web components thing we think it's the
bee's knees here is a sample application
you get all the skeleton for you you've
got HTML you've got the custom elements
the CSS so let's just run this here to
see what it's like it's very simple here
but we're going to run it in dartium see
it pops right up no compiles time needed
click me ok button click on ok cool so
it gives you just the core to get
started with let's look a little bit how
this application is written hopefully
you can see this so the polymer element
looks pretty much like what eric was
showing you earlier so the HTML aspects
of building highly declarative apps with
dart are very similar to the JavaScript
side the difference though instead of
implementing the custom element with
JavaScript you can implement it with
dart dart has classes so it makes a ton
of sense to be able to say one class for
one custom element so this is cool and
I'll show you a couple other features
because Dardis structure and this editor
gives you some nice productivity
benefits let's say I want to add a reset
count and then a method here ok code
completion because we can statically
analyze your program we know what you
can call right here and it's real time
so that's pretty awesome and also going
in for the local stuff as well ok that's
pretty cool now the other neat thing
about statically analyzable language is
it can understand your program so let's
look at this field count notice how it
only highlights the uses of that field
it's not doing a string search and
replace here so it leaves out some of
the other accounts even though obviously
it's the same string so we can do we can
rename we could say my account and it
only renames actual usage as a field
again the power of a statically
analyzable language i'm going to undo
that scared of bugs ok cool let's once
you're in an editor and you have an
actual virtual machine you can set
breakpoints so let's go back we set a
breakpoint there we're going to rerun
the app and if I click the button and it
all works yes ok great so it jumps back
to the editor and you're in a familiar
editing environment with full
breakpoints you can inspect this is
really cool I can jump in here on
inspect this instance I don't know if
you guys can see this actually trust me
that's his count and then five to live
object in space
dur so that's really cool so the let's
move on this app was kind of neat but
it's also kind of boring so I think we
can do a little bit better in fact that
that grey button I want to make fancier
so this is where a package management
system comes in if our package manage
system pub let's see if we can go here
has over 500 packages and are ready from
our open source community everything
from server side stuff to client side
stuff the game crypto you name it oh
look at this fancy button ok so our pub
package management system also has
custom elements in it so if you like web
components you want to reuse them a
package managed system is a great way to
do that so let's make our button a
little fancy let's load up the pub
specta llamo file this defines my
application and its dependencies and
certainly I depend on polymer let's
depend on fancy button ok great so now
the editor is kicking off pub he's going
to go download it and install it and
make sure I'll worse my app I'm a little
impatient so I'm going to go over here
and show you what that looks like we're
going to win a quick click whoops click
counter and just like regular web
components and HTML imports you can
import the definition of fancy button
you can say that this button is a fancy
button now this is all backed by Dart
it's a real web component and it came to
us from that package management system
let's see if I indeed made it a little
fancier so run in dartium and yes
awesome ok pink ok so it's a nice just
demonstration how you can use a package
for instance package management system
and reuse code finally we need to get
this out into the wild it's one thing to
iterate very quickly in dartium but it's
another thing to be able to find my
original slides beep ok do your final
testing and production browsers like
Firefox and stable chrome and this is
where a pub build system comes in so
iterate very fast with dartium and the
editor and then run a nice build process
now more and more web developers are
moving to a build process it does really
nice optimizations for one ours runs
start to jsu saw some of the nice
optimizations can actually do with your
code tree shaking it can minify your app
if it totally knows your entire
application you do a really smart job
minification
and you can also do concatenation you
can take all your dependencies all your
custom elements and jam them all
together into one single file making the
deployment and performance very very
good in fact in this particular example
I mean you saw ate a lot of dependencies
third-party stuff custom libraries core
libraries this app compiles down and G
zips down to smaller than some CSS
frameworks you guys use so I think it's
kind of cool and just to show you that
that all works here we have it in
Firefox and it's the same this is dark
compile the JavaScript using web
components deployable to a production
browser today this stuff is real and you
can use it ok and then when you're
finally ready to go you have a nice
build directory which has just the
assets just those minified files in a
very nice director you could pick up and
put onto the web all that concatenation
all the minification done for you nice
and simple nice and simple so how do you
get started well we relaunch the website
we have a really nice code lab takes
under an hour wat SI through 0 to 60 you
get to build a really cool pirate name
badge generator so a really nice way to
try dart build for if you don't know
anything about dart and I want to leave
you with reminder that dart one point o
is for the modern web it's a platform
you can use today it's easy to get
started go to dartlang.org with api's
code labs articles tutorials and
everything you saw here even the web
component stuff all compiles to
JavaScript so you can write dart take
advantage of those great semantics
language and tools and still deploy
across the modern web so I think with
that whoops I think we're all ready to
go okay thank you very much